[Music]
in Korean we say hi annyeong haseyo so
please use it in Korea when you visit
someone yeah
I really I really appreciate you joining
this session because I have never
expected such a huge audiences because
it's a last session of the Google cloud
next really appreciate in this session
there are three speakers
I'm Jason customer engineer at Google
Cloud
I look after netmarble and SVG sensei we
usually call him sensei the great
teacher
he's a Solutions Architect at Google
cloud who has strong expertise in AI and
machine learning and Jennifer is a team
member of netmarble who is very talented
the ML engineers so here our content in
this session we're gonna talk about the
the case studies of netmarble in terms
of normally detection in MMORPG so in
the beginning I'm gonna talk about the
brief introduction about netmarble and
what is their business and why they
chose machine learning to detect of
users so after that a cg will be
presenting about the challenges what
they have faced to leverage machine
learning models in order to detect
anomaly Texians and he's gonna present
about the solutions what netmarble
is currently using and after that
Jennifer is talking about the
collaboration between Google Cloud and
netmarble in order to accelerate their
process and also enhance the model and
after that jennifer and i will be
talking about the next steps about the
deploying multiple I may hype lines and
also enhancing the and the empowering
the detecting powers and there is a
doric the torii in the cloud app so you
can have a questions very freely by
using the
Renet so in order to use story Q&A
please open your the cloud next app and
tap our session and you can submit your
questions to the Dory then we're gonna
handle the questions but unfortunately
we have limited time so we are not gonna
handle during the session but I promise
that I'm gonna handle every question so
feel free to serve me your questions so
yeah I'm gonna talk about the brief
introduction of netmarble and their
business and I'm gonna give you the
region Y netmarble chose machine
learning to detect those kind of the
abnormal users this is a brand logo and
the brand symbol of netmarble the brand
symbol is a yellow dinosaur yeah it
looks like alligator but yeah dinosaur
yeah so the dinosaur named cuckoo-cuckoo
means that just lapping in Korean so
when we usually have fun then just we
just say yeah something like this so we
yeah we usually have fun then we just
say kick in a text message so the name
is very related with the name Marvel
missions so net Marvel's mission is that
the entertaining the word with the fun
games so netmarble usually try to deploy
and release the fun gaming title too and
they entertain the real world and here's
some numbers presenting netmarble yeah
as you can see netmarble is the third
the game publishers in global and also
they already acquired 68 millions multi
their monthly active users and this
number is larger than her career
population so we can see netmarble is
focusing not only Korea but also global
business in order to entertain the world
named ma who already has 19 subsidiaries
as a development studios and 5000 plus
the employees as game developers
here are key products of netmarble
so the lab two things played in Seoul
Revolution
Lee needed to Revolution which MMORPG
mobile MMORPG so those two products are
really popular in Asia and the
generating more than 100 million dollars
and also the right two things are very
popular in Korea named the seven nights
and also though you know mobile yeah
this is mobile game
so the Marvel future fight hit the world
and just acquire the millions of users
in the world so as you can see the the
key product of net marbles are high
fidelity games which is easily to
acquire lower users and also heavy
spenders so servicing high fidelity game
it's very important to create a big
revenues and there are key success
factors are two things the first thing
is that acquiring the heavy spenders who
is willing to spend more than a hundred
thousand dollars for game yeah it's
crazy but true yeah you're really true
yes and the second thing is that the
retaining that kind of heavy spenders in
a long time in a long lifetime so in
order to do this nameable usually
leverages the the most famous eyepiece
such as marble future fight yeah is used
mobile IP lineage to and blader so is
developed by ncsoft
but it's really popular in Asia so
netmarble leverages this IPS to acquire
most of heavy spenders and in order to
retain those kind of heavy spenders an
empire should manage the ecosystem of
the MMORPG game because if the habit
spender feels that someone is stronger
than me without spending any money then
they just yell oh this is just a unfair
game and they just leave the game yeah
they just leave the game and they just
try to find another MMORPG so managing
the ecosystem is the most key part of
the success of the the high fidelity
games so netmarble usually the try to
manage the ecosystem but as you knows so
many peoples are coming
then someone someones will be a bad guys
so in this case we call them abusers so
there are some of the abusing cases in
MMORPG the first case is that they try
to abuse the the bug of the some of the
marketing events or content updates so
for example the Terra M has some bugs
you know the in-app promotions so some
abusers they cheated to get some
multiple reward by clicking multiple
times due to that issues it made high
inflation of the gaming economy so the
most of habit spend adjourned
they're very immediately and the second
thing is that some of the abusers they
just try to hack the client
vulnerabilities such as the memory
hacking or just some of the yeah trying
to sense a multiple message to get be
were multiple rivers yeah and also the
last thing is that some genius hackers
they usually uses leverage a spot to
generate income resources yeah
automatically so some the abuser stay
just running 10th yeah 10,000 part to
generating income resources and they
just try to sell it to the market yeah
so naima will try to block those kind of
users by using Roo based model yeah
because it's really accurate and it's
very easy to understand so then when an
nth marble planned to release the game
they just designed a business model at
this time business de belem team also
designed the rule rules to detect some
abusers for example the if the someone
reached out to the 100 level
in in awake then that kind of players
might be an abuser candidate something
like this and after that the rule is
designed and they just send it to the
development team to ask some game loves
to check the user behaviors and also the
QA team they verifies whether the laws
are successfully stored and after that
there will be releasing the title and
let me assume that the game logs us
successfully steward to the storage then
business intelligence team they try to
investigate and they just analyze the
gaming laws to analyze the user
behaviors and they just apply some the
rules to the rule based model and they
just run the Rubies model in production
then the rule based model will be
detecting some abuser candidate and that
the rule based model will be notifying
to the off team to investigate this
abuser candidate is abusers or not
so of team and development studio they
collaborate to investigate those kind of
user activities and also if DEP abuser
candidates is truly of users then they
just blast the users and if nah it if
there is a first alarm then the
intelligence team they change the code
and they modify the rules to detect the
right abusers but as you can see so many
teams are engaged and so many processes
and it takes a long time to modify and
change it the rule based model so as you
as you seen there are some problems to
run the rule based model the first one
is that honestly it has the small
coverages to detectable users because
it's actually working on rule based
model so if that someone is abusing
without rules or without some
unpredicted the behaviors then grew base
model doesn't expect this is an abuser
or not and as you see that it's really
hard to keep up with the speed of the
con
update and new patterns because mostly
that in order to retain the heavy
spenders the most important thing is
that the development studio keep
continuously updates the content to
spend money so mostly they are focusing
to develop the game features and they
usually deprioritized to adding a new
rules new yeah the rule based they
adding the new rule based model so it's
really hard to keep maintain the rule
based model due to their issues net
marbles are try to decide to leverage
the ml technologies in order to learn
from the user behaviors instead of
adding something by hands so in this
section a CG sensei will be presenting
about the challenges what s e-g and net
model has been faced to leverage ml
models and also or he's gonna giving you
the solutions what nel marble is
currently using so please welcome a CG
on the stage okay thank you Jason and
here everyone I'm it's Regina Kai I'm a
Solutions Architect for Google cloud
platform I'm based in Tokyo Japan and as
you know the customer netmarble is a
company based in clear so I traveled
quite a lot times last year to clear to
meet a customer and help them develop
the machine learning model to solve the
problem that jason has just explained
and I conducted machine gun workshops
for them several times actually quite a
lot of times and of course I'm not
complaining about it
it was laser exciting very pressure Pro
a pleasure experience for me because
some of you may know that having a
conversation about machine learning with
a customer is always challenge
because it requires a variety of
knowledge for both of us first we must
understand what is machine learning we
must know the nature of the date set and
we must know the business goals in other
words we must have the domain knowledge
in this case it is a knowledge in the
gaming industry and in that sense the
collaboration with netmarble the data
scientist team in netmarble was a
perfect example for me
because Annette Maru they have the very
strong data scientist AI team focusing
on AI technology they have very good
understanding about machine running and
they know the nature of their dead set
and they are naturally the experts of
the gaming industry so what about the
Google side first
I'm a machine learn experts I have very
deep knowledge about mush running I can
say that however I don't have much
knowledge in the gaming industry I don't
play mobile games very much
I'm solely Jennifer however on the
Google side we have the customer
engineer Jason he has a very deep
knowledge and experience in the gaming
industry so by sharing our experience
and nourish we collaborated very
successfully together to achieve the
business result and for now I will
explain some technical details of the
machine learning model they used they
developed together with asked to detect
abnormal users or abnormal data and okay
this is a very short answer they use the
machine learning model code ode encoder
to detect abnormal data this is a very
simplified diagram of the out encoder
but actually the mechanism of auto
encoder is very simple it is a machine
learning model to regenerate the same
data as impt on the outside so we train
this machine learning model to minimize
the Delta between input and output and
the question is how and why we can use
this machine learning model to detect
abnormal data to explain that I prepared
a simple tiny toy model using the M nice
date set M nice date set is as you know
the collection 118 digital images we
barely enough we use this data to
explain some basic mechanism of machine
running so this is a kind of hello world
example but anyway I will show you some
code
okay can you turn to the demonstration
okay this is a club not a book I
implement the tiny toy model on this
notebook so let me go through this
notebook first I import some modules and
I download the EM nice they set and I
define the machine learning model code
encoder I don't explain details of the
code but if you know about chela's you
can understand what's happening i
defined a very simple neural network
model with six layers and i will train
this machine learning model to minimize
a delta between input and output by
using the MSE mean squared error term as
a loss function and i will train this
machine learning model initially with
just a little data only for a single
epoch and this is a result the top side
is the input data and the bottom side is
the output data you can see that this
model is now trying very hard like a
small child to lea generate the same
data but it's not perfect so I will keep
training I train this model with some
additional data for more epics and you
will see the leaves out like this one
okay it's forbidden out and now I will
use this trend model to detect some
unknown some abnormal data okay I draw
some number on this white canvas and
first I try some simple one just number
zero and use these alleles out the app
is very similar to the input and now I
try something different
I draw not a number that a letter B
can you guess what would happen yes the
apt is different from letter B it looks
like number eight or number Slee yeah
this is because I train this machine
learning model with only numbers so it
always tried to regenerate some data
similar to numbers so in this case the
out is totally different from the impt
so by comparing the input and up you can
say that if the Delta is very large this
input is different from training data
this is something different from numbers
this is a basic mechanism can you go
back to the presentation okay so once
you train this machine learning model
with normal data you can use this
machine and model to detect abnormal
data by comparing the input and output
very good however now you are faced with
a technical challenge number one no
label data as I told you you need to
turn this machine learning model with
only normal data to do that you have to
split your whole dataset into two parts
normal part and abnormal part how can we
do that we need a machine learning model
for that so this is a chicken-and-egg
problem I think this is a very common
problem in the gaming industry generally
they have a lot of lot of data but they
are not well organized they need some
tricks to organize those data so that
they can use that data for machine
learning however sometimes you need
machine learning itself to do that so we
had several discussions how we can solve
this problem and our solution is
surprisingly simple we use the whole
data in
fooling abnormal ones to train this
machine learning model and naturally we
have similar assumptions behind that one
of the biggest assumption is that the
amount of abnormal data is very very
small compared to the normal data so the
inference of abnormal data will be
simply over little by the huge amount of
normal data of course this is just an
assumption we have to verify that we
tried several different machine learning
models to check our assumption and
finally it actually worked
sounds good I guess some of you are now
thinking this is too simple this is
different from what I expected to hear
yeah however in reality the most
important part of applying machine
Roenick to your business is to choose
the best and simplest national model to
solve your problem it is a very tricky
part to do that you have to understand
variety of machine learning models pros
and cons of them and you need to choose
the best and simplest one it's very hard
and that's why I'm here I can help you
for that I actually have net well for
that anyway before going to explain
another technical challenge I wanna
explain the production use case of this
machine learning model now they the
trend is machine learning model everyday
using that fresh data in past two days
and after Li training the machine
learning model they deployed a trend
model to the production system and then
they use the same year time gaming ROM
data to detect abnormal users and then
they create a list of suspicious users
and send the list to the operational
team and finally the operational team do
Mannion further investigation to have a
complete evidence that some users did
actually something long and then they
decided appropriate action against those
bad users and again you may have some
questions first question is why we have
to retrain the model everyday because
the data freshness matters in the world
of online gaming especially in MMORPG
the user behavior always changes due to
some reasons sometimes they have some in
gaming event daily list new game
features and characters every day and
even reserved those are elements
maturity of users naturally influence
the behavior of those users so it's a
kind of natural evolution in the virtual
gaming world so to keep up with these
changing realities we have to retrain
the model every day with the fresh data
and the second question is why manual
investigation isn't it machine learning
to automate everything is an it a good
idea to automatically block but users
unfortunately it's not a good idea from
several reasons one of those reason is
to avoid false positives it is really
bad if we block some normal users
mistakenly it's a last thing we want to
do and the second reason is to decide
the appropriate actions against bad
users is sometimes very tricky
suppose that we found several users who
did something wrong just one time from
curiosity and what if they are very
loyal users they spent a lot of time for
that game they spent a lot of money in
that case simply blocking those users is
not a large business delay our decision
so they have to understand a little
nature of those bad behaviors they have
to understand the lair of nature of
those users to decide the appropriate
action against them that's why they need
a manual investigation and the last
reason is somewhat interesting by doing
manual investigation they can understand
some new patterns of abnormal behaviors
and apprise those knowledge to the
existing load based model to improve
them you may have so that once we create
a machine learning model we can slow
away all the existing old rule based
models it is not the case in some cases
rule based model works better than much
learning it is a reality so combining
machine learning and Lulu based model is
the ideal solution and in this
particular case they can get new insight
about a new patterns of abnormal
behaviors because machine learning is
very good at finding new patterns
automatically and then they can use that
new finding to improve the existing rule
based system so this is a very good
virtuous cycle okay now we are faced
with the technical challenge number two
it is model explained ability what it
means because the operational team needs
to do some manual investigation they
need some hint why this machine learning
model detected these users as abnormal
without any reason they can't do the
manner investigation effectively they
need some heat from the machine learning
model this is the problem what we
generally call model explained ability
and to solve this problem the AAI team
in that model apply the feature
engineering it means instead we using
the original raw data to train the
machine learning model they combined
those
low data low features to create some new
features those are interpretable and
explainable and then they use those fear
engineered features to train the machine
learning model and after the training
they can compare the Delta between amped
and opt for each feature if some
specific feature has a large Delta it is
exactly the reason why this machine
learning model detected this user as
abnormal and this feature is
interpretable operational team can use
this information to do further money
investigation effectively and this is
the overview of the feature engineering
the AI team in network applied the
original data is naturally a time series
data because this is a gaming log data
and they aggregated this time series
data with 60 minutes time window to
create new interpreter features and you
can see some functions or formulas they
use to advocate to create interpreter
features unfortunately details of these
features or formulas are confidential
these are very very important
intellectual property or netmarble
they cannot disclose everything but if
you have some knowledge in data science
or at least statistics you can guess
what they are doing to create some
interpretive features okay and this is
the last slide for me instead of using
the standard normal odd encoder model
they decided to use stacked denoising
auto-encoder
to detect abnormal users I don't have
much time to explain what is denoising
auto-encoder but I will give some key
words the most important keyword is
spirit over effect
by using the denoising feature you can
avoid the spear over effect of standard
or encoder and by avoiding the spillover
effect you can improve the explained
ability of the model if you are really
interested in that you can search some
academic papers with the keyword
denoising auto-encoder and spill over
effect basically by avoiding a spillover
effect you can specifically identify the
feature which affects the the Delta
between input and output preset some
academic papers for details okay anyway
now Jennifer from netmarble will talk
about some technical detail order of
their machine learning pipeline and how
we have collaborated together to achieve
the actual business leads out please
welcome Jennifer to the stage thank you
for having me at eg hello everyone my
name is Jennifer Ehle I am an engineer
in the mobile and I also key member of
anomaly detection project I'm here to
share two kinds of challenges we had and
how we solve them Oh before we start
there's a little dinosaur on the right
right top of the screen you might want
to check how the emotion changes by each
slide anyway so so the first challenge
was this we have so many game titles and
these game titles have unique user
behaviors as you can see on the screen
there are some MMORPG games adventure
RPG games and also others and and these
games have a very different data schema
in their distribution since all the
games were made by our substrate
companies so therefore we
nurturing all the data into one model
that means we needed at least one model
product per game that's a huge amount of
model products so we said we thought
that we needed a standardized platform
that could handle multiple model
products so the solution for this was
simply GCP using TCP because standard
light is a whole whole system and I said
let's check them out and in detail so
using TCP we did not have to manage the
machines and services since they are all
managed we did not have to make new API
functions since all of most of them are
already made so even if he had like new
game titles which requires new functions
we did not have to make them all so it
was easy to scale the system scale
change the system scale which is very
important whether you want to use
distributed environment or not or no
matter how large scale you want to use
we did not have to change anything
except a line in your config file or the
CLI command let's say suddenly a game
deu has doubled in a day which might
happen in a few games and so the data
size will be doubled - in that case
normally we have to like add some new
machines to some serifs and test but in
our case we don't have any worries like
what's the big deal about it we just all
we have to do was to just change the
number of nodes from 10 to 20 so with
these reasons we were able to
standardize this whole system so let's
check out our system architecture as you
can see on the screen all the game data
was saved on bit Cori so we use dataflow
to extract data from bigquery and
pre-processing and all the pre-processed
data would be saved on GCSE using the
CSV files we're on a training job on ML
engine when the training job is done the
exported model will be saved on GCS so
using the GC file saved on GCS we can
register the model on Imagine so that we
can use as prediction let's move on to
the prediction process
so starting from the pre process files
which is same as the training part we
run a prediction job on ml engine I mean
the M prediction job is done the
predicted results will be saved on GCS
and we can just upload the CSV files to
be query and then send the predicted
results to our customers which are came
operational team so all this process is
also scheduled by Jenkins the process is
run every day or maybe even every hour
so gives me how many people we need to
manage this whole system just one or
maybe even less so if we want to apply a
normal detection to a new game all we
have to do is to do data EDA and some
feature selection since all that game
data are all different we might do some
pre pre preparation for the data
pre-processing and change the model
parameters and it's ready for the
production so that's it for the first
challenge we have and let's go move on
to the next challenge
so this is our next challenge we have so
we wanted good model performance so in
order to do that we had to read more
papers and blogs and run some tests with
multiple models however we were running
out of time and we do not have enough
human resources
so we chose to collaborate with Google
let's check down check them in detail so
the first thing we did was having
workshop with heg sensei
so we explained our situation and our
problem and he shared his thoughts and
ideas so we did architecture
brainstorming together and model
algorithm brainstorming together and
after a few days he gave us a fantastic
idea about online education which our
current system is mostly based on Thank
You Gigi and so we had the idea and the
next thing we had to do was run some
tests with on multiple model algorithms
and find which one is the best for our
system so the next thing we chose to do
was to do Google PSO project the mobile
and the PSO team ran nvm about different
model algorithms in parallel such as
statistical model esteem deep
autoencoder and stacked denoising
auto-encoder with the results from each
team we were able to choose the best
model that fits our system there were
also many supports from the Google
Technical Account Managers and customer
engineers like Jason and also we had
best bring global who's our CCP partners
they were there to help us when there's
any problem with CCP and also they
shared us some updates so that we can
prepare for the updates and also they
probably many supports so we could have
a smooth collaboration with Google as a
result we finished our project
successfully and efficiently what I mean
by efficiently is that we only used few
human resource and also feel time let's
check the model our results
developers perspective and also users
perspective this is a graph showing
number of users daily as you can see on
the graph there's a light blue graph
which is showing the number of
suspicious users detected by the model
the dark blue ones are the ones who are
blocked by by the operational team so as
you can see most of the users detected
were invested investigated by the
operational team and they were turned
out to be abusers using HEK tools so
they were blocked from playing the game
again this is a graph showing number of
abuser reporting posts on public webpage
so in normal users the abusers when
they're playing game they prop some post
saying to complain about the abusers or
to request us to block them they will
get angry if they see the abusers
winning so easily so the number of user
reports were used to be that high but
once the anomaly detection was released
the number the graph drop down stiffly
this happened because the copies of the
ML model was much larger than the
original rule base model that Jason has
explained so that's it for the
challenges we had and let's move on to
the next part so from now on let's find
out what find out about things we are
gonna do in the future until now in the
mobile we were running many AI projects
besides from the anomaly detection
there's a project action which is
detecting some fraud information sent by
the ad company there's Ross
prediction which is predicting return on
as
and there's gold farming detection which
is detecting users who run thousands of
posts to collect real game users
there's test automation which is using
AI model to run a game function test
there's auto balance evaluation which is
also using AI model to test the game
balance automatically and also last but
not least the voice command which is a
playing game automatically using the
users voice well in the future we are
planning to do more and more AI project
we are going to extend the AI to all of
our businesses and we are gonna enhance
partnership with Google of course and we
are gonna do more collaboration and
cooperation with industry University and
also Japan and North America AI
companies so that's it for the name
outside and let's hear more about the
technical side bye Jason
ah Thank You Jennifer
for the the best message is for us so we
are still very closely working with
netmarble
in order to enhance their ml models and
ml pipelines so we are trying to do some
technical challenges still yeah
technical challenges so the first thing
is that we are collecting label data as
SDG mentioned it's really hard to
collect label data in reality because no
one know abusers they don't want to yeah
guess site yeah they just want to hide
so in order to leverage the current
models the detecting power is increased
up to 10 10 plus times so we are
collecting more blocked users and we are
just thinking what if we can leverage
those kind of blocked users as a labels
so if we can leverage those kind of
blocked users and their features and
user behaviors then we can develop the
the supervised learning models so
autoencoder is based on the unsupervised
nano learning by clustering some player
behaviors so we are also trying to
leverage the supervised model by
leveraging blocked user information and
second the challenge is that we are
still revamping and pipelines so as as
Jennifer mentioned all the ML pipeline
is based on our the managing solutions
but then Marvel chairman is very
satisfied the performance of current
models so he is encouraging to deploy
their ml model to new releasing gaming
titles it means that they have to manage
more than 10 plus the ml models in this
year in order to support this we are
trying to migrate their ml pipeline to
cawelo pipeline to accelerate the model
development and Allah
part is that we are trying to do
ensemble running so as Jessica mentioned
we are not only using single motive
but also we are leveraging loo based
model and we are trying to use the
supervised learning model and the other
models
to empower the detection yeah so we are
used try to use ensemble learning so
hopefully in next next year yeah I'm
gonna give you more detail about our
challenges so that's it thanks for
having this session and I want to give
you one more thing is that your feedback
is highly appreciated so before you
leave the stage please complete the
survey on the cloud on a cloud next step
thank you everyone
I'm Tom Miele thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you